Scrabble nah we're back here I'm wearing
my sexy outfit I don't know where to go
oh yes oh yes of course this start
Superman's original sorry I still don't
understand why he's like take me
although F it's my home
I'm not trough from this word I was born
on the planet Krypton
oh it's baby kal-el I get it he's not
bending over he's a baby
alright let's go No what am I supposed
to do provide a container for SIFMA's
kinds to place him inside okay how about
a duck and exploded no duh but what
about Cotulla no a Becks
come on a box what LC wine really
you're gonna put him in a [ __ ] bomb
wait crying you dicks one fateful day I
discovered that I had incredible
strength give Superman something
extraordinary lift giant penis what I
would have been extraordinary oh okay
I'm sorry
a giant Viking there you go
Oh what [ __ ] move his hip what a
giant [ __ ] how about that everyone is
happy there you go that is extraordinary
later I found out that I could fly max
will happen into the air see ducks has
to do everything they don't get enough
praise Haga fly Superman really the
balloon works I quickly found out that I
needed a cigarette Dennis I could live a
normal life when I wasn't being Superman
Maxwell gives him and something that he
can use to disguise himself I don't know
thank you what yes like the carpets of
course even though I was Superman I
still needed a job I wanted to work at
the Daily Planet news agency Maxwell
helped Clark Kent get a job at the Daily
Planet
um I don't know how do you get how do
you get a job I don't [ __ ] know oh I
resume there you go
holy [ __ ] you forgot your dresses
Superman fine if no one's gonna wear the
dress I'm doing it
alright it's not that I want to yeah
it's a shame to waste a dress all right
oh [ __ ] I burned my ass help the [ __ ]
are you I don't know what to give him a
stop break stop why do you always do
that the shark is [ __ ] them promote
the to the plane nice smooth shark there
you go you [ __ ] oh yeah you better
[ __ ] die due to my alien heritage
let's do that never trusted me
he is kryptonite to try and destroy me
max we'll find a way to protect Superman
from the probe night oh I don't know how
about Dan yet Rotelli
how much family's wagon laden he's fine
he's fine he's fine what is that now
it's [ __ ] he's faking it you're an
attention [ __ ] fine all right
shabby let's put fine he's fine there
you go what is he doing oh okay
I used my incredible power to set effort
further my incredible powers powers for
those who cannot stand up for themselves
I lost one world I'll never let that
happen to this one how many people have
you saved I don't know max oh but that's
not the point people need someone to
look up to someone who can inspire them
to fight I guess evils of the world
we're lucky to have you Superman but
don't forget you can have the people of
the world to whenever your injustice end
up here I'll do my part Superman
what a [ __ ] idiot all right we need
to go to a new area okay let's go back
to Gotham because we haven't finished
Gotham yet so we might as well try and
finish the [ __ ] Gotham let's have my
rainbow car Yolo I love this soundtrack
in this place - oh there they are
help me oh [ __ ]
oh no it's come on what am I supposed to
do my name is PewDiePie and justice make
my butt cheeks jiggle hotter than a
Japanese porno I need you to quiet down
the cloaca or else I'll blow my cover
are you work oka all right let's me he's
a mute what yes but he still died so
what's the point
she's Caesaria at me sir all right the
line has been cut to my town hall
connect the telephone pole turn I mean I
don't mean to tell you how to do your
job but hey [ __ ] go no you crazy
[ __ ] hey shark are you doing go ducks I
always get dicks this game's up for
murder
my duck army is ready to fight crime of
Gotham a shed they can't climb stairs
[ __ ] [ __ ] llama can spit yes ok
make someone else for them obsess over
how about one direction an OK decoration
there you go you know what you disgust
me
go llama I love superheroes oh thank you
[ __ ] don't ever show your face here
again kill himself
my dark army oh my duck it hatched holy
[ __ ] how did that happen
my god I'm gonna be a mom all right
there you go obsess over this a little
bit there you go
no way it's Catwoman you're the best hey
just cuz I don't have tits doesn't mean
I'm awesome okay
what do you want [ __ ] it's [ __ ]
spectin all the dirty peasant all right
what else what else can we do here
I don't know what's up with that [ __ ]
doctor but that guy is having a great
party we forgot to meet I don't know
it's magnetic why does my jock have to
die no well I'm bringing one of you on
[ __ ] idiot you know what I gotta
[ __ ] spit out here [ __ ] did he just
spit out a chicken that's amazing
what the hell is they doing why don't
wait where the hell are you a
fire-breathing duckling okay hell's yes
I'm picking up that [ __ ] all right
[ __ ] kill him one of my ducks the
fighting bringing the ability is amazing
I can't breathe don't worry about it
there you go she'd all be better now no
how about just spit on her okay now I
don't see she's fine she's fine
you're welcome that'll be 50 bucks Hey
don't you dare touch me no more vish
wishes until I get my wish I want a
vehicle okay you're welcome
I wish I knew how to drive stop
following me
no come on get out of it what did I do
what's up what's up what's up wait can I
make the duck spit
oh my god that's stupid as hell all
right we finally have enough to to do
bad mess mission so let's do that
my story is born out of tragedy tragedy
when the morning's and in that sorry
before that night I had everything the
night I lost my parents I was all alone
in the world
max will find a way to comfort him hey
yo you want a duck
wait you're not happy you spoiled little
[ __ ] whatever the kids want these days
at an x and x max if that's what you
want
Oh what are you gonna do with that girl
ha ha ha ha when I returned to school
there was a bully oh sure he's huge
it was much no [ __ ] but I needed to
learn to be brave applying a digging to
help me stand up to the bully hey guy
have fun
criminals are cowardly superstitious lot
I know that I needed a guys to strike
terror in their heart a creature of the
night what what could it be given
something spiders constant I don't yes
the thing it doesn't feel right huh
maybe you should wear it in a different
way I don't know why it's not a [ __ ]
[ __ ] now you're just being picky
oh nice
what an oh you wanna bat that doesn't
even make sense
what when I first started fighting crime
I needed to down from trust from the
police get mad about something he can
use to help Commissioner Gordon there
you go poof that [ __ ] that's right
that's right
and that's how the joke was born I
fought all my life for justice I'm glad
to know you're out of there fighting
good fighters well if I watch then who
will
that's right Bruce I like your attitude
[Music]
you need to learn how to very close no
all right so we're done Batman
we don't Superman we haven't done all
right next time we do a Green Lantern I
hope you guys enjoyed watching leave a
like if you ended let me know if you
want more of these series I will keep
this going as long as you browse one
more hit the sky come birthday I'll see
you in the next one
stay awesome no it's gonna win come on
we could go on forever Lily